I'm so sad and I remember the first
speech of Barack Obama which I heard in
2004 in the Democratic convention
endorsing John Kerry he said there is no
blue state and red states of america I
know only United States of America so
such a long way done since this first
speech of the young senator of Illinois
we are so far from the United States of
America which he was thinking of at
least I'd America is divided as as never
because of because of what a lot because
of mr. Trump a lot because of the sort
of campaign he did vulgar populists
agree she's counting on fascist portions
in part of his electorate and this has
created an unprecedented Division in the
American Society I like division it
belongs to democracy is part of
democracy democracy is of course a
society divided with itself inside
himself but not to this point if I had
to make a parallel i would say probably
Berlusconi in general America shows the
road and Europe follow in this time it's
a European country would show the world
and America has followed because the the
pattern the pattern The Godfather of the
sort of new spectacular populism
populism based on TV populism based on
real television is Silvio Berlusconi in
Italy exactly the same he started with
the same program as well Trump he acted
with women exactly as Donald Trump is
reported through
fourth to behave he had the same shot of
the size of his enemies and of his
friends as fun and he does Connie
created the same sort of division which
you are facing today in America and it's
not very good news because these did
cost a lot to Italy Italy which is the
very fatherland of art and beauty was
partly damaged if not destroyed by these
Berlusconi eras years because this sort
of non politics it is not politics
politics either is a brave great world
what Berlusconi off from do is not
politics it's something else it's a
circus it's games of circuses games of
Scrolls deals as a tram says it's cool
as it is not politics it does not have
the nobility operating so these sort of
non politics damages strongly a country
and for someone like me who is so
attached to America I was defined years
ago by my friend Adam Gopnik as an anti
anti American anti-americanism for me
the plague I hate that in some form of
fascism and patty Americanism itself so
for me who is a I am such a lover of
America such a friend as a guy spent
month of my life to wing American the
footsteps of Tron villain 13 years ago
it is heartbreaking if Trump has full
powers if he acts in America like in in
the shop of toys where he can buy the
biggest toys or eat the best pastries
and fulfil himself with the most creamy
pastries in can find in the bakery then
it will feed anti-american
if the civil society in this country
reinvents the check and balances system
which will be frozen with the Republican
Party who gets everything congratulate a
lot of Governors and so on so the the
balance the check and balance have to
come from elsewhere from the treasures
from the associations of citizens from
new protest movement which are still to
be born in this works then I think
America will give to the world a new
image of itself which will be a great
one which will be an image of a great
nation standing firmly on its feet and
values and own world against cartoon
cartoon president if there is a sort of
democratic uprising democratic peaceful
uprising of receiving societies saying
not in our name if abroad we have the
feeling that some of the acts which will
be done are not done and taken in your
name or in the name of a big part of
society that maybe it will improve the
image of America and the world
[Music]